[música]
Oh, no se puso bonito
condiciones
[música]
planetario de tomsk
baleado el 21 de mayo
Eugenia Lvovna
53 años
pensionista fusilado el 10 de septiembre
descripción
Monumento a Alejandro Stanislavovich
realiza una campaña de retorno anual
nombres
donde la gente común y los viejos y los jóvenes
leer los nombres de las víctimas inocentes de la Unión Soviética
autoridades
gran don na bianchi
en ese momento en el complejo de estos edificios
término interno localizado KVD
aqui
24 de abril, 41 trajeron arrestados
mi abuelo
Mi abuelo Stepan Ivanovich Kuznetsov
1889 año de nacimiento
condenado a 15 años y sobrevivió Eterna
memoria
este año el memorial fue prohibido
celebrar una acción explica el coronavirus
tendencia del Estado ruso en
actualmente en la clandestinidad
verdad historica
no quiero estar asociado con
ganadores
pagado quiero olvidar
[aplausos]
y este documento
Yo lo llamo la lista del abuelo
de esta lista comencé a buscarlo
colegas en chino oriental
ferrocarril y empezó a interesarse
su destino en realidad comenzó con esto
mi
una búsqueda tan grande para montar yaks lo
esposa tiro
tiro de rollos
comenzó a recolectar materiales
todas las operaciones nacionales de nkvd
y los materiales resultantes que vendí en
archivo conmemorativo
monumento
es la asociación pública más antigua
personas que llevan en la sociedad la verdad sobre
lo que sucedió en la URSS durante los años
represiones y durante los años del Gran Terror
Esto es lo que más consideran.
lo mejor que he podido hacer hasta ahora
hacer protocolos
Comisión de la NKVD y el Fiscal de la URSS
que se mantienen
en el archivo del FSB en la región de Omsk
Está prohibida la copia en los archivos del FSB.
así que tuve que
reescribir estos protocolos contienen
la información más valiosa porque en ellos
cada persona sometida a
represión
ante estos documentos ante nuestro
viajes en el decimoséptimo año nadie
obras
[música]
estos documentos se mantienen en formato regional.
departamentos FSB y no están disponibles en
Todas las regiones
cuantos reprimidos
que se frustra en estas regiones Nadie
no lo sabe, excepto los oficiales del FSB, pero ellos no
deseoso de compartir este conocimiento con
sociedad
Dijeron que eran secretos
justificación para imponer restricciones a
acceso a los documentos que
desclasificado por completo esta burla de
justicia azul sobre la ley
secreto de estado
Servicio Federal de Seguridad
utiliza los mismos métodos
utilizado por sus predecesores
se consideran herederos de la VChK OGPU
NKVD
la memoria del abuelo
albacea oficial superior de la calle con
se me acercó con un palo de goma en las manos
poner mis piernas entre tus piernas
y con un palo de goma para encontrar los pies
feroces golpes golpean antes de perder mi
conciencia
[música]
cuando recibimos mandatos en 2016
los miembros del público no comisionan en
la primera vez que vi cuando un hombre
toda la suela negra
[música]
aquí está la zona industrial de la ciudad
Angarsk Donde se encuentran cuatro colonias
y también un centro de prisión preventiva de donde nos vienen
denuncias de tortura zona industrial
construido a mano
prisioneros de guerra, incluidas las manos
bien condenado
Aquí ella está en una colonia penal
número 15 en abril
2020 hubo una protesta
contra la violencia y por lo tanto resulta
reunió a más de 500 personas
Fueron colocados en SIZO-6 de la ciudad de Angarsk y
SIZO-1 de la ciudad de Irkutsk de donde es de ellos
resulta que noquearon confesiones
testimonios que supuestamente
organizado
rebelión
Cuando
vienes directo al shkonke te sientas aquí
esta posición así te sientas y
cabeza, simplemente no puedes ver nada
co allá atrás o algún movimiento
solo se te acerca y te patea
golpean con los puños con los pies
los propios desarrolladores los desarrolladores son rostros
de entre los prisioneros en lugar del hecho de que ellos
torturados ganan así que tú
digamos alcohol hay drogas
Estábamos bajo el shkonka por la noche, ni siquiera
visto más
aqui en este rincon estan esta siberica
solo torturado estaba gritando ya hay una voz
no tenía
a menudo acampar sin estación
reclutado del pasado criminal
elementos
[música]
los desarrolladores también
vinculación fecha vendaje fuera de la cama
el hombre cuelga esencialmente estirado y puede
un día cuelga puede colgar una semana puede
se puede permitir un mes de ahorcamiento en anal
pasillo un trapeador de algún tipo tal vez una escoba
Sí, podría ser una caldera.
hay casos en que una persona de casa
recoge a los operativos y posteriormente
simplemente desaparece
Hola Pavel Mi nombre es Sí Siberia
sin tortura, la organización nos dijo que
estás en problemas aquí
Y
le dieron patadas en la cabeza
lo sacaron de la casa, le tiraron una bolsa encima
al parecer tenían miedo de que los vecinos vieran lo que habían
su cabeza siempre es aplastada mientras la declaración está en
comité de investigación hablemos
recogido
para que el siglo XXI aún no sea
nadie tocará nunca
En 2016, los empleados llamaron a nuestra puerta
la policía le pidió a mi esposa que les diera
asistencia en la revelación de casos especialmente graves
delitos después de la entrega al departamento
la esposaron a un banco y
según estableció la investigación, ardieron durante 3,5 horas
se aplicaron descargas eléctricas y posteriormente estos
empleados fueron condenados a 3,5 y 4 años
prisión
eso es todo lo que queda de los dos pisos
casa antes donde planeábamos vivir después
litigios de empleados
la policía prendió fuego a la casa en abril
las consecuencias fueron un incendio pero
los culpables aún no han sido encontrados
en 5 años no nos ha pasado nada
del hecho de que fuimos envenenados por un perro y luego
Hay
tiró tubos debajo de la puerta
mujer maltratada
en nuestro caso, un testigo desapareció, logró
testificar que ella era
llorando en el departamento de policía antes y después
no pudieron volver a preguntarle
ahora él
tienen un sentimiento de impunidad
[música]
aquí
verdugos que participaron en
represión
no fueron condenados
El Partido Comunista y su líder.
Stalin no reconocido como criminal
reconocida como una organización criminal nkvd y
Este
da
base para los verdugos modernos
contar con el hecho de que ellos también están en
el futuro no será condenado
Audiencia del Tribunal Supremo
Federación Rusa está abierta
escuchar un caso administrativo
eliminación de público internacional
solo organizaciones internacionales
prácticamente una sociedad de caridad
monumento
[música]
esto es un crimen
un crimen contra la historia
países
poco a poco mejorar la zona
ayuda de un voluntario
podemos 10 dash debajo de eso entonces cuando
conoceremos a todas las victimas y participantes
represión
Si no tengo documentos de archivo
tendrá acceso a estos documentos, entonces puede
decir lo que había en el lagan
serie sofia